hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of
uh of day two this is a game from round
six of the paris and blitz rapid and
it's maxine vashilagra versus yanni
ponishi so
two of them faced each other in the
candidates tournament as you know jan
won the candidates tournament but now
they are facing each other in rapid
uh maxim has the white pieces and it's
uh it's a really interesting game
features a most impressive move i'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it but before we
check out the game
uh a few words about the tournament
yesterday so thanks everyone for joining
uh the tournament when great it was two
hours of pure action
uh we had a lot of players uh almost
five thousand
like uh four four thousand nine hundred
and sixty four players and
the winner uh of the tournament was a
mysterious person
that goes by the handle a senior and
in the end when i contacted him he
refused the prize he said that
he only played for fun he said happy
birthday and he said that
his prize money should go towards the
the second winner
uh so that's uh he was awarded
the first prize as well uh and uh seven
chesmar was also
uh awarded the the third prize two more
prizes will be awarded it's uh
a gesture from uh michael castano he
said that he will pick the two winners
that
the the two players uh that um uh played
a lot of games but they didn't do all
that well as that kind of reminds him of
uh how he finishes the tournament so he
will
uh pick those players but uh we're gonna
uh we're gonna we're gonna
uh get to that don't worry so here these
are the top ten a senior in first place
manila
in second uh grand master chess mode uh
zaven
uh in third place heisenberg one in
fourth ferocious line
in fifth uh vulgar rasholov in sixth
uh vincent kymer who also played in
seventh place he joined very late but he
had a very very successful tournament
uh international master matthew g uh in
eighth place
mitra by international mastery 9th and
international master rosh kevin
uh in 10th place so congratulations to
everyone who
uh joined and uh well big
congratulations to the winners it's not
easy
uh playing basically bullet for for two
hours because most of these guys
berserked their games as you can see my
near monday
uh berserk's 71 percent of his games is
even uh
berserked 76 percent of his uh games and
the winner a senior uh berserked 32
percent of his uh of his games
so really really impressive stuff uh so
that being said uh
let's check out the game and as you can
see uh up uh
uh above the board age of kaiser chapter
two is available the link is in the
description
so uh first you're gonna have a link to
the actual manga and then a link to the
stories but i will do a separate video
after this one regarding the manga
regarding the stories regarding the the
progress
uh of the creation of the manga what's
happening so far so you you guys
will be well informed but now let's
stick to the game maxime with the white
pieces opens with e4 and here
uh we have e6 nippo decides to play the
french against
the frenchman and uh he he's gonna show
him how it's done
but maxime says nope that that's not
happening
uh he says uh d4 we have d5 and now
e5 going for the advanced variation of
the french c5 striking in the center we
have c3
nicely strengthening the center and not
knight to c6 we have knight f3
and now bishop to d7 uh sorry knight to
f3 and bishop to d7 going for the max
over variation
uh also uh known as the the paulson
variation so obviously
paulson i played it before irv but then
also made it very popular
we have bishop to e2 and now knight g to
e7
uh we have h4 starting to push that h
pawn
and now the position has been reached
before no moves or something like queen
to b6
rook to c8 capturing on d4 these are all
known moves but the move that
nipple plays is uh a new one so not only
does he play the french defense against
the frenchman he also plays
f6 in a position where f6 has never been
played before
so it is now as a move seven that we
have a completely new game and maxime
needs to
figure out how to go about this and it's
a very uh it's a daring move because
obviously you can capture here mess up
black's king side then capture here even
win a pawn so
what's the idea behind this uh this uh
well pawn push
well he wants uh if maxine captures on
f6 g captures and d captures on c5
he wants to play e5 and now he has this
massive center yes his king side is
ruined a bit but maybe he can just you
know develop
get his king to the queen side and uh
well maxime does not want to play this
he says okay you prepared this i'm not
going into it
however our silicon friend really likes
white after b4
probably you know preparing b5 to kick
away this knight also preventing queen
a5 so
how are you going to play this with
black but uh
maxim not interested in testing nipple's
preparation
uh he just continues pushing his pawn so
he says h5 and now
queen to b6 by nipple putting more
pressure on the center here
and attacking the b2 pawn so now the
bishop can be developed for the moment
we have g4 maximum says this is how you
play against the french you just push
pawns you don't have to play with
pieces you just push pawns and that's it
good things will happen
nipple now goes back knights the g8 now
takes care of these squares
and now the bishop can also be developed
perhaps
so knight the a3 now the knight has been
developed the knight can now come to c2
he can go to e3
uh or even to b5 if needed so here we
have c
captures on d4 nipple breaks the tension
in the center
c captures on d4 and now f captures on
e5 we have d
captures on e5 and the bishop to c5 now
putting pressure on this
f2 pawn uh and here maxim could
definitely just castle here defend his
pawn here
uh and say okay it's a pretty pretty
weird position but maybe i can play this
but after knight to h6 going after the g
pawn it's uh uh how do you how do you
continue this with white it's just very
very ugly
you have to play something like knight
g5 to defend this pawn but then you give
up this pawn then black has
just a massive control in the center and
you know black is coming for the white
king so
instead after bishop to c5 we have
knight to b5 maxim says
this is not a problem you can have your
f2 pawn and here nepo
has to decide whether to capture the
pawn or not but
he doesn't he actually plays a move uh
that seems to be
even stronger maybe it's not but it
seems to be uh he plays
knight captures on e5 and now he says
all right now your knight is attacked
the f2 pawn is attacked and also your
knight on b5 is under attack so what do
you play here
uh here we have knight captures on e5 uh
maxime grabs this knight
and now again uh nipple makes a very
interesting decision he
doesn't grab the f2 pawn he just picks
up the knight here
and he allows whites to castle and it's
very very hard to justify
uh such a move uh who who who amongst us
would not play bishop captures on f2
it's simply
a move that must be played you don't
even think when there's such a move
uh why wouldn't you play it that's the
question i can't figure out
the reason behind nipple not playing
that but he just
allowed white the castle he played
bishop captures on b5
and here maxim quickly castles the
safety but
of course who are we to question uh the
the world chess championship challenger
obviously there's a very good reason
behind it
so here knight to f6 he continues
development but now comes
bishop capture some b5 with check queen
captures and now
g5 uh removing this knight from from f6
knight to e4 now with a nice double
attack here
and now comes queen to g4 putting
pressure on e6
uh but nepo deals with this very easily
he just plays queen to b6 now uh the
the the the queen the bishop and the
knight are all attacking the f2 pawn
and the queen is nicely defending this
uh e6 pawn but this is where maxime
starts getting
really really creative uh here maxine
plays g6
and now what do you play here uh well
it's uh it's a very tricky tricky movie
if you play some like bishop captures
and f2 we're just gonna play king to
king to h1
and now again how do you continue this
it's a it's a very ugly position
if you go for material knight g3 check
we can just play king to g2
now there's a double attack on your
bishop and if if you pick up the rook
we're just going to play queen to a for
check
and now you're lost uh uh we're either
going to check may the king here or
you're going to
go here and it doesn't help if king here
we're just going to play queen d7 and
there's no defense against
this checkmate so really really uh
incredible stuff
uh so of course he didn't go for that he
could play h6 this is also very
interesting and this is the best
thing to do then we'd see some like
queen f4 going after f7 but then
rook to f8 attacks the queen and now
knight f7 so it's a
it's an ugly position maybe but black
really doesn't care because the white's
attack is over he's just going to
continue developing
and you know still enjoy his very very
very good position here
so after g6 we have queen side castles
uh he doesn't care about any such
threats but now maxime
really gets a lot of activity here he
plays bishop to f4
and now the bishop slicing all the way
here and the queen slicing this way is
gonna make life really hard for the
black king
uh you can never move the king because
then you go into the line of fire of the
bishop so here
he plays h captures on g4 and now
rook ate the c1 and look at how
everything is starting to make sense
here this is uh
this is the good stuff uh being made and
now the problem is if you go for
something like rook captures on h5 it
kind of doesn't make sense you might
want to double rooks on the h file
you lose the game on the spot knight
captures on g6
and what do you play now how do you how
do you continue this game the rook is
being threatened
and once you move the rook we're just
gonna play b4 and the bishop cannot move
the rook is in c1
so you'd have to capture with the queen
but now you give up the e6 pawn
queen captures on e6 and this is now
game over uh you're going to play rook
d7 just queen to e8 to check
rook to d8 and knight to e7 will be
checkmate
so incredible stuff so after rook 8 to
c1 we have g
captures on h5 now it comes with an
attack on the queen so white
does not have time for any knight to g6
action
so instead we have queen to g6 and now
comes
rook hdf8 attacking this bishop uh black
would even be very happy
happy to give up the exchange to
eliminate such a strong piece uh but of
course maxime knows this he just moves
the bishop bishop to h2
and now comes rook to f6 with an attack
on the queen
the problem is if you go all in right
away i mean why wouldn't you you're
attacking the f2 pawn four times the
problem is we can just capture this
and after knight captures we can just
play rook characters on c5 and this is
this is the ugly truth uh because now
what do you play you're in check you
can't move the king otherwise you go
into
in front of the discovery so you'd have
to capture here and now we simply play
queen captures again with
check king b8 and knight to d7 wins the
queen there's also
a double check so the king has the the
king has to flee
uh so here after bishop to h2 we have
rook to f6 attacking the white queen and
now
queen captures on g7 uh and now
here you have to play knight captures on
f2 this is the
uh this is this is the critical position
where knight captures on f2 has to be
played and now after the king moves you
want to avoid any discoveries now night
back to e4
and the game continues so this is what
should have happened in the game
uh if the the greatest moves were played
however in the game
rook captures on f2 was played and now
it seems even deadlier because now the
rook can simply move anywhere
uh and open up a discovery it seems like
white cannot defend against
all of the threats but uh unfortunately
for
nipple white uh doesn't have to defend
because it's actually white who's
attacking here
so here rook captures an f2 was played
we have knight captures but now
the problem is white has such a
devastating move that completely
shatters all of black's hopes so feel
free to pause the video here
and try to find this move for maxine
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
such an incredible move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show uh
it's queen to h8
i'm only joking uh it is of course
knight to d7
it is uh such a such an ugly move to
face and
when uh uh when nepo saw this he
immediately resigned in the game
uh so he was in this position on move 26
that the yani pony should resign to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
look at this this bishop slicing over
here the knight
at end the rook attacking the bishop
here and what do you play here yeah
there are some things you can try
let's say you try a discovery knight to
d3 check you want to pick up the rook
but white says not a problem we're just
going to eliminate this bishop with
check and my knight is still attacking
your queen so you're going to lose it
whatever you play knight captures
knight captures with check and there is
no move for the king you have to capture
the knight and after pawn captures queen
to c7 will be checkmate
and there's even a maybe a sturdier
defense
after knight to d7 we could go knight to
d3
uh or rather night the d3 knights the h3
so we deliver a double check so now the
white king has to move
but now we play king g2 and now again
what do you play here
the queen is still hanging there's a
double attack on the bishop now the
knight is hanging as well
so of course we're gonna capture the
knight why wouldn't we but now comes
queen the f8
check disgusting i know uh with a double
attack on the bishop here so the rook
has to block rook to d8 and
now comes rook captures on c5 the king
is well pretty much helpless here so you
have to play something
queen captures on c5 now we're just
gonna capture with the queen
or uh you don't have to capture we oh
okay we we can just show it
if you capture with the queen uh king d7
and now we simply uh go for the
go for the attack king the e8 we're
gonna play queen captures on e6 with
cher king f8 and now king captures an h3
uh this is uh simply unplayable uh and
if you don't capture the rook if you go
king to d7 right away
uh well then queen to f7 is mating one
so there's also that
and uh lastly uh you could consider
something like uh
after knight e7 you could maybe not
deliver a check maybe you could pick up
the knight right away but it's the same
thing queen to f8 check rook the eight
rook captures on c5 and basically it's
the it's the same thing
so really really incredible game uh
nipple uh had
something going on uh after that f6 move
he really
uh he had a had a great position but at
some point uh he he just missed
you know he lost the threat of the game
and here in this crucial moment where
uh he was supposed to play knight
captures on f2 he played uh
he captured with the rook and then in
this position of course
knight the d7 was played so really
really incredible
uh what a move to take down the leader
and after the
uh after the three uh three rounds uh i
i think there are three leaders uh i i
am going to check
i don't know if uh let me just check
uh yeah so it's uh yeah i think nipple
nipple wesley and
fabi are leading the tournament so far
but there's still one day of of rapid so
we're gonna check it out and see what
happens
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it really an impressive
feat taking down
the world championship challenger like
that with such an impressive move
uh yeah i would like to thank michael
castagno uh david kimura rajesh
uh anata svimanatan kurt wandler and
christopher dick for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
but i would also like to thank uh not
that
let me just load this for uh really
quickly
uh all the people that contributed to
the uh prizes for the tournament
yesterday uh here are
all the people that contributed so thank
you for that uh
so all in all i i donated 1 000 for the
tournament and you guys donated
and sixty two 367.62 for the tournament
and here's everyone who donated
sebastian broad
uh singhara uh venkateswara chandra
chakra chakravarti uh peter spence david
bagooli
purna sujay charakuri uh kurt wandler
christoph uh christoph deagleman uh
khaled mastery
james michael castano uh abhinavisha
kyapan
richard j lindquist stage presence and
john austin
so thank you all for the contribution
you've made towards uh towards the
tournament
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon uh continuing the coverage
of everything that's currently happening
in the chess world yes we will continue
the morphe saga
uh and of course whatever else happens
so thank you all i will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out
everything that's been going on with the
manga the first two links in the
description below but the next video i'm
uploading
is actually regarding the manga itself
so you can also just wait for that
see you soon